I can't
say you don't show and don't move
[Applause]
this morning on the dish goklin Juan
needs a writer and Chef who's found
International success serving up the
taste of his childhood Chinese takeout
with five books currently in print and
another about to come out Juan has
unique insight into how to recreate that
delectable takeout moment MTS tie up
went to his home in Leicester in the
British Midlands to find out why
for goklin Wong there's no place you'd
rather be than in the kitchen there are
three flavors in Cantonese cooking which
a garlic ginger spring onion
he cooks in his newly remodeled home in
the very same building his parents ran
their Cantonese style restaurant back in
the late 1970s
for the British city of Leicester it
introduced locals to Flavors from the
Far East part of a tradition that
started with his grandfather who opened
his own Chinese restaurant in the area
nearly two decades earlier for the chef
and cookbook author these are the Taste
of Home
including his personal favorite spring
rolls or what his parents had on their
menus as pancake rolls so any idea why
these are called pancake rolls in the UK
in egg rolls in the U.S I had no idea
I've got no idea either
for one along with his brother and
sister helping out in the kitchen was a
fact of life for growing up but we
actually used to live upstairs as
children but that just meant we were on
tap or on hand all the time so when mum
and dad got busy downstairs it literally
was you know someone had run up and get
it or my dad actually had an internal
phone system installed in every single
room so if you're upstairs watching TV
yeah it didn't matter which room you're
in the phone rang we're busy downstairs
come and help wow so we're going to take
a one-ton wrapper okay
um okay since then little has changed we
were called on to help too starting off
making wontons
okay I just pinch them together
like so nearly
that's your first attempt yeah let's
just say I'm not a natural one
yeah fold it over to filling spring roll
wrappers with a mixture of carrot napa
cabbage bean sprouts and water chestnuts
and I'm guessing this is your first
spring roll wrap it is how did you know
it's better than your one turn wrapping
I think so perfect but that is what we
call a spring roll that's better than
mine that's really good I'm pretty proud
of that that's great one is the author
of several cookbooks but a life in the
kitchen isn't something he always wanted
he left home in his twenties to spend
his days learning Kung Fu and his
Knights working as a bouncer at
nightclubs
and I loved every minute of it going on
to open his own martial arts school
where his love of teaching and food led
him back to what he does best and I
thought well you know what I can cook
and I I've got all these recipes that we
used and used to cook you know cook in
the in the restaurant let's teach people
how to cook the food not only the food
that we were eating but the food you
were eating every time you went to a
good Cantonese or Chinese Takeaway or
take out my Kung po King prawns so one
started posting recipes online of the
takeout Classics he learned to cook as a
child very very simple sesame seed
Prontos now if you like it Saucy add
more earning him a loyal following that
led to regular appearances on national
TV pork sugar and an upcoming eight-part
series for Amazon
there seems to be this undercurt of
nostalgia to what you do why do you
think it connects with people in that
way so when I wrote my first book I
listen to music that we listened to when
I was working in the restaurant in the
1980s and it helped me remember the
feelings I had when I was cooking or
eating those dishes I remember Billows
of smoke coming off the hot plates when
we served the okay beef or the Canton
beef they're trying to recreate moments
with their own family when they sat
around a table eating a Chinese takeout
or in a restaurant much like this one
used to be exactly
but for us he cooked his all-time
favorites those spring rolls
[Music]
the crunch the flavors the freshness
perfect good
good I'm pleased kung pao chicken is
that hitting the spot no that hits the
spot right with the cashew nut now and
you're getting that creaminess coming
through you see it's got this sensation
yeah and your mouth kind of like those
trust you pork and a classic chow mein
another all-time favorite you cannot go
to a takeaway and not have chow mein no
definitely not
and the key to cooking really nice chow
mein is to let it burn a little bit that
sounds crazy but adding that charred
flavor just adds that extra element of
texture and flavor all made with
ingredients that can be found in nearly
any grocery store anywhere some could
argue this is not authentic what do you
say to that
it's as authentic as you ate
30 years ago it's as authentic as I ate
45 years ago so why is it not authentic
just because it you know at the end of
the day every single dish that we eat
now has evolved from somewhere and for
goklin won that Evolution has taken
place here in the house where it all
began two things I can do right and
that's cook
and I'm yeah in Kick I'm the original
Kung Fu Panda dumplings in kung fu
dumplings and kung fu for CBS Saturday
morning India's tired Leicester